the year is 33 A.D it's the night before
Jesus is killed he is praying In The
Garden of Gethsemane when suddenly there
is a flash of blue light a team of
assassins from 2022 has successfully
time traveled to 33 A.D their mission is
to kill Jesus and prevent his
resurrection so that Christianity can be
wiped out before it's even born the
Assassin starts scouting for Jesus and
his disciples who have all fallen asleep
just then a large mob armed with swords
and clubs comes to arrest Jesus and
crucify him however the Assassins who
have arrived to alter history quickly
interrupt them they start shooting
everyone in sight and leave no one alive
except for Jesus after a while they find
him lying on the ground with several
bullet wounds one of the soldiers tells
Jesus that if he's really the son of God
he should have been able to stop the
bullets however Jesus answers that this
time has already come the soldier then
pulls the trigger and kills the Son of
God then they put him in a bag and with
the help of a time traveling watch-like
device returned to the present in the
meantime a group of good scientists
witness what has just happened they
figured that they must quickly travel
back in time to undo everything because
their reality could change to a new one
as the past has been altered they then
travel back in time to 33 A.D to save
Jesus but they're too late they have
arrived just moments before the
Assassins have finished off Jesus and
his disciples they literally have a time
machine how did they screw that up now
they have to quickly go back to the
present before time rewrites itself as
the current timeline can be overridden
by a new one since Jesus's death however
when one of them successfully returns to
the present he's captured immediately by
the Assassin group but soon reality
starts to change the office building
starts to warp into an apocalyptic
Wasteland in this timeline it's clear
that humans have gone extinct soon
underground creatures start to rise and
feed on him killing the last human left
on Earth then the screen Fades to Black
following this the movie flashes back to
a few months before everything
transpired we are introduced to one of
the villains that will kill Jesus his
name is Brandt an ex-military officer as
of now he's still a devoted Christian
who believes in Christ however
everything is about to change on a
seemingly beautiful day he's out on a
drive with his wife and kids it turns
out that Brandt has been offered as the
head of security for a top secret
company so he's traveling to another
state unfortunately along the way the
family gets into a horrific car crash
taking the lives of Brant's wife and
children Brant screams in horror as he
watches his entire family burn in a
flaming rack because of the incident
Brandt has now turned into a man-hating
life and God he blames God for not
saving his family at this point the
former militant also questions the
existence of divinity following this we
meet a young and aspiring scientist Ram
Goldstein he meets Amy Lee one of his
classmates for the first time during a
physics test from that point onwards
they start to develop romantic feelings
towards each other the movie then skips
to three months in the future and we
meet a group of young scientists led by
Ram their ingenious grads including
Felix Simon and Amy who are working on a
project involving matter trans inference
for a non-specific global company run by
A well-dressed and worldly Arab
billionaire named Ahmed and as it turns
out Brandt is the head of security for
ahmed's company in a lab the young
scientists worked tirelessly on their
matter transference project when Ram
tests one of his algorithms the team
mistakenly blows up the place this makes
Ahmed the boss himself come down and
check on his scientists but what the
team doesn't know is that they were able
to move the chair which RAM used to test
his matter transference algorithm are
they sure it wasn't the explosion that
moved it this discovery earns the team
an upgrade into ahmed's top team the
billionaire promises them a handsome
bonus in exchange for creating a matter
transporting device in the meantime a
flashback is shown where we learned that
ahmed's parents were once part of an
extremist group but because of certain
events they were forced to convert to
Christianity and because of this change
they were murdered at the hands of the
extremist group on grounds of betraying
their own faith since then Ahmed who is
still loyal to the extremist group
blames Jesus Christ Christ and
Christianity for the death of his
parents he wants to have his scientists
work on a time machine so that he can go
back in time to 33 A.D and kill Jesus to
discredit him as the Messiah ultimately
wiping out Christianity he believes that
his God is the only true God and with
time travel he can go back and right the
wrongs of the World by killing Christ
before his crucifixion and Resurrection
meanwhile RAM and Amy continue to work
tirelessly as they're being monitored 24
7 by ahmed's men they decide to take a
break for a while and sneak into the
server room where they aren't surveilled
the couple make out but they are
interrupted by a weird static sound when
Ram checks on one of the servers he
finds out that Ahmed is secretly working
with a generic terrorist group he
further learns that the terrorist their
boss is working for is hell-bent on
waging World War III through matter
transference technology with bombs and
weaponry transferred from one place to
another despite learning this he is
forced to continue with the mission and
after a couple of Trials and errors Ram
finally succeeds in transferring matter
and accidentally creates the world's
first time machine ahmed's men see via
surveillance that not only has Ram found
the secret to matter transfer but he
also discovered the secret to time
travel however since Ram knows that
Ahmed is up to something bad he tries to
delete all the files before they get
into the wrong hands soon enough Ahmed
and his men Storm Into the lab and
apprehend Ram then the cunning
billionaire Reveals His plans to send a
team led by the now disillusioned Branch
back to Jerusalem where they will
assassinate Jesus Christ and his
disciples thus making sure Christianity
never comes to fruition but the problem
is that Ram wouldn't give him the code
to the computer that hides the secret to
time travel so Ahmed has his men torture
him put him in a sack and lock him in a
warehouse after a while the thugs
physically abuse RAM and urge him to
share the code of the time machine to
make matters worse Ahmed arrives at the
scene and holds Ram's parents hostage
despite this the young scientist still
refuses to share the code so the
extremists kill his parents there goes
all their leverage meanwhile Amy and the
others are worried that Ram might be in
trouble as he's not answering his phone
just then the group is approached by
their employer Ahmed who tells them that
they have been cleared out of their
contract and will no longer have to work
although each of them will be
compensated as promised the only catch
is that they cannot make any contact
with anyone outside their work at the
moment when Amy asks about Ram Ahmed
lies saying that he is in safe hands in
fact working on a top U.S military
project back in the lab Ahmed threatens
to torture Amy and all his friends and
that is when the young scientist finally
gives in and agrees to build the time
machine and as soon as it is finished
Ahmed has one of his men tested as
expected The Time Machine Works and the
man is teleported from one place to
another playing on Bran's hatred for God
Ahmed uses him and his right hand man
sabir to gather his combat team and
travel back in time to carry out the
ultimate true mission to kill Jesus and
his disciples before his resurrection
surprisingly branth is totally down with
this insane scheme and quickly assembles
a team of Assassins to hop inside the
time machine meanwhile Amy and the
others sneak into a surveillance room
and finally spot Ram who is tied with
rope in the warehouse they rescue him
and learn about ahmed's plan on the
other hand Brant and his team have
successfully landed in the past at the
set time
ie-33ad and starts scouting for Jesus
after killing all of his disciples Brant
viciously shoots Christ in the head he
then as his men put Jesus in a bag and
they return to the present in the
meantime Ram along with his genius team
Witnesses what just happened from the
CCTV Ram starts to explain that their
reality will soon change to a different
one as the past has been altered however
it may take some time for it depending
on how far back in time it has been
altered it could take minutes or even
hours hearing this the team immediately
travels back in time in an attempt to
stop Brant but they're too late they
have arrived just moments before the
Assassins have finished off Jesus and
his disciples now they have to go back
into the present before time rewrites
itself as the current timeline will be
over written by a new one since Jesus's
death RAM and Amy decide to go first and
in case they are killed Simon and Felix
are their last hope to stop Ahmed and
his crazy mission in the next scene RAM
and Amy arrive an hour early in the
present that is just before Ram's
parents were murdered this means there
are still the second versions of the
scientists in this timeline along with
Brandt and his assassins Unfortunately
they are soon spotted and chased by
ahmed's men the pair barricade
themselves in a lab where they are
eventually cornered however Amy manages
to warn her second self from the current
timeline via the CCTV camera she
explains through sign language that
ahmed's men went back to kill Jesus and
that they have to save Ram who is in the
warehouse that's some Advanced Sign
Language shortly after the pair is
killed elsewhere Felix and Simon are
still in 33 A.D after waiting for the
now dead RAM and Amy the pair decides to
return using their time retrievers Felix
successfully travels to the present
while Simon has his retriever broken and
gets stuck in that timeline badly when
Felix arrives in the present he finds
Ahmed and his men waiting in the time
machine at this point Ahmed has
succeeded in creating a world without
Christians by Killing Jesus however
their reality CERN turns into an
apocalyptic Wasteland this is because
he's created an existence without
forgiveness slowly this version of Felix
dies in The wastelands this means the
first versions of the scientists have
all died except for Simon meanwhile the
second versions of the scientists
watched the CCTV footage and quickly
rush to rescue Ram from the warehouse
they even go to the lab and go back in
time even further hence creating time
Loops within time Loops they travel back
in time just 10 minutes before branth
and his men arrive in 33 A.D a firefight
breaks out which kills both Felix and
Simon only RAM and Amy make it out alive
from their team while Brant and sabir
Escape however Amy is severely wounded
in the encounter as a devout Christian
she wants Ram to go after Brandt and
sabir and stop them from killing Jesus
Graham doesn't want to leave her alone
but when she insists he agrees he then
takes off his clothes this is no time to
get naked and binds them around Amy to
stop the bleeding oh after a while Rams
spots a beer and starts chasing him in
the meantime the first version of Simon
is still alive in his timeline as he was
stuck there because his retriever
apparently fried up surprisingly he gets
to meet Jesus and reacts with all the
awe and wonder of coming face to face
with the Son of God Simon tries to
convince Jesus to not go through with
the resurrection because he's seen the
movie The Passion of the Christ however
Jesus insists that he's going through
with it explaining that it is the only
path he can take soon Jesus is captured
by the large mob to be crucified later
Ram also meets up with Jesus and his
abductors however when he tries to
initiate a conversation a Roman
Centurion tries to assault him luckily
he manages to escape and goes back to a
dying Amy and to everyone's horror he
realizes that he and Amy's time
retrievers have been disabled by ahmed's
men back in the present because of this
they now have no way to get back home
the following morning granted severe
disguised themselves as locals and Scout
the village for Jesus but nothing goes
as planned when sabir steals a tomato
from a local vendor and eats it without
paying a penny it turns out that this is
a grave crime in this 33 A.D timeline so
the local guards are called to arrest
them however sabir puts up a fight and
shoots one of the guards this causes
chaos but finally the guards managed to
outnumber the two and take them for
crucifixion tomatoes are not worth it
man during the fight sabir loses his
time Retriever and it is later picked up
by a woman in the next scene Jesus is
also taken for the crucifixion he is
forced to carry his own cross while
being whipped by the guard seeing this
Simon asks Jesus to escape but the Son
of God is adamant on finishing his duty
to save Humanity Simon then helps Jesus
to stand up and Carry the Cross moments
after the procedure is done Ram arrives
with a dying Amy who wishes to see her
God in person he pleads with the now
crucified Jesus to save his girlfriend
if he really is the god that he claims
himself to be however Christ claims that
Amy can only be saved by forgiving
Brands that's nonsense we also see that
the criminals crucified alongside Jesus
are actually severe in Brant where the
latter asks for Jesus's forgiveness
meanwhile realizing that Jesus isn't
going to do any miracles to save his
girlfriend Ram vainly tours around the
village for help he then finally meets
with Simon and tells him about their
situation elsewhere with Brandon sabir
out of contact Ahmed decides to travel
back in time and arrives at the Tome of
the recently crucified Jesus he believes
that Jesus's disciples will steal his
dead body soon to make it seem like God
has been resurrected hence he plans to
Ambush them from stealing the body and
eventually prevent the spread of
Christianity suddenly there is a massive
earthquake and in that moment of panic
he activates his time traveling device
which makes him and Jesus's body
disappear from the tomb meanwhile a
dying Amy mistakes the shake for her
God's Resurrection when RAM and Simon go
to the tomb to check they do not find
Jesus's body and seeing all the glow
sticks lying around they deduce that
Ahmed is responsible for it just then
two of Jesus's disciples arrive to check
for Jesus's body and find out that it
has disappeared but before they can
report it to others RAM and Simon claim
that Jesus has been resurrected the two
disciples mistake the boys for angels
and immediately believe them hence
everything in the scripture happens as
it is but not the way we expect it to
they then return and find that Amy has
breathed her last this means that this
timeline version of Amy is dead too
while grieving for their colleagues
demise RAM and Simon are approached by
the same woman who had picked up Sabir's
time retriever earlier with this the two
decide to go back in time just before
Ram's parents were murdered in that
timeline all the characters are still
alive they travel back but since ahmed's
men have been waiting for them Simon
gets gunshot wounds despite this the
boys managed to kill all the men
following this Ram asks Simon to execute
the default program which will eliminate
all the time Loops except the original
one and to destroy the computer hard
drive as soon as it is done he then
heads out to save his parents after Ram
leaves Ahmed from the previous timeline
arrives and kills Simon but the latter
has already destroyed the hard drive and
executed the default program meanwhile
Ram saves his parents and goes after
Ahmed from this timeline at the
Billionaire's office he finds Brandt and
nearly shoots him for killing Amy in the
previous timeline but he eventually
realizes that this is not the version of
Brent who did the deed Ram eventually
accepts Jesus's advice and learns the
power of forgiveness refusing to Revenge
kill this version of brance just then
sabir along with other men arrives at
the scene with Amy as hostage he
threatens Ram to give him the code to
activate the time travel device or else
Amy will be killed but instead of
revealing the code Ram mentions that he
has forgiven Brant and asks him to be
the hero thankfully in this version of
the timeline Brandt hasn't yet turned
into a villainous character so he
quickly realizes that Ahmed is the bad
guy working for the extremists he then
guns down most of ahmed's men before
being shot dead by the boss himself
taking advantage of this slight
distraction Ram stabs Ahmed in the back
finally killing him just then a group of
FBI officers arrive at the scene and
arrest ahmed's remaining man since Simon
has activated the default program
moments before he died all of the time
Loops start merging into one prompting
different versions of the characters to
vanish Into Thin Air thus Ram from the
previous timeline also vanishes while
the original version is set free from
the warehouse where he was initially
capped in the end all the scientists in
this timeline survive the movie then
skips to three months later the
scientists plan to save Brant's family
from the tragic car accident Ram
prepares to time travel with a road sign
that says stop hoping that it can save
the family genius fortunately the plan
works and he is able to save Brant and
his family from their untimely death the
movie ends as Brandt stands in awe and
Ponders if God helped them cheat death
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching